today's question comes from emily in
louisiana she writes in
i will graduate from college debt free
this year
with an mba i'm taking fpu currently
and i want to work for a company that
matches my values and is passionate
about helping people
change their future as i start looking
for jobs how do i decide my career path
and then find a company
that aligns with these values sounds
like she needs to come here
she does and she might be tipping us off
there we'll have to see
a very simple process that i teach and
you use your talent that's what you do
best think hard skills soft skills
to perform your passion that's work that
you love
think of a task a function a role that
you just love doing
to accomplish your mission that's
results that matter deeply to you so
how you figure out if a career path is
the right one for you which by the way
dave
when you figure out where those three
gifts from your creator align
talent what you do best passion work you
love mission results that matter when
they come together it looks like this i
use what i do best
to do work i love to accomplish results
that matter to me and here's what
happens when you answer those
questions what i do best what work i
love what results i want to accomplish
then we're looking at job descriptions
we're looking at career paths and we
just simply go
does this particular career path with
the jobs that are on that path
do they allow me to use my talent do
they allow me to do work i enjoy
and do i create results of matter once
we figure that out dave what we're going
to see is
multiple jobs career paths and even
dream jobs
in that contribution zone or in other
words the sweet spot
and that's how you determine which way
to go
and she's asking also about aligning
with the company
that aligns with her values so
because some companies are very real
mission and values driven and others
just
want to hire you to get the work done um
and you've got an mba and you can do
this work and it could it could fit all
of those three things
but you get plugged in as a robot that's
correct into a place that
doesn't really it in a sense is agnostic
in the sense that it has no values
that's not values driven it's right it's
driven by performance it's driven by
well i guess that's a value
sure but uh how do you in the interview
process let's coach her a little bit
um find out if the company
is um you know going to be political
cutthroat
performance climbing on the bodies of
the people behind you in front of you to
get up to
get up the ladder uh or or it's going to
be caring
and missional and how do you find that
out because com
you know people put on their best face
when they're doing interviews but
companies put on their best face when
they're interviewing that's exactly
right and then there's let's go a step
deeper there are some leaders in an
organization that'll have a different
answer than the actual
top level leadership so you've really
got to do your homework beyond the
interview but to answer your question in
the interview you want to ask questions
like
what kind of person wins here that's an
open-ended question a lot of
hiring managers don't get asked so
they're going to be one of two responses
there if they're uh oh and they're
stumbling all over themselves that means
they actually haven't thought it out
that should be a warning sign i wouldn't
call it a red flag but a yellow flag
if they answer in a way that is just
very flat
and it just sounds like corporate jargon
that's a red flag
and if they say some things that make
you go whoa that doesn't sound like the
kind of person that i am
so you're asking an open-ended question
what kind of person wins here
how do the company values show up in the
workplace every day that's another
open-ended question
if they've if they've thought about it
like at ramsey solutions
if a hiring manager here can't answer
that question well
uh they've been on medication and it's
not a normal day for them we know
we can say here's how the ramsey
solutions values
enter into the hallway into meetings at
live events
when we're talking on customer care so
you need to ask questions like that and
the answers themselves the quality of
the answer
the lack of an answer is going to reveal
a lot to you now
back to that the the the three part
uh indicator that i laid out for folks
when you know
what results you want to create and you
say okay you know i
i think this concludes that other part
though before you do that
okay i think you can smell the air in a
place oh you can
i i mean if they were walking around
like a bunch of stepford children
all all buttoned up corporate crap then
you kind of you kind of got a or if
they're sloppy
yeah and and they're they're you know
they're not on time
uh um you know they're just uh
you know like they all just were smoking
pot at the break you know i mean or
whatever
yeah obviously do you feel kindness in
the air
happiness in the air do you see people
uh
when they're walking are they walking
really slow like somebody just
whipped them and they got no hope or are
they walking a little too fast
because they're because they're stressed
out it's a little too fake a little too
clean a little too perfect that's the
step forward
i think i think you kind of got to look
for those kinds of things tell you yes
but i'll tell you what else
smell the air you can smell the air but
again that's not going to going to be a
complete indicator because
because you got to do one thing i think
that people do
that would be smart is to look at vendor
reviews if you can do some homework and
see what are their vendors what is a
company's vendors some people out there
now you don't take one comment but if
you could see a pattern of people going
they don't treat their vendors well they
don't treat their customers well
that's also a big sign yeah and again
i'm not talking the one or two
i'm saying if there's a narrative where
customers go
these people big business they don't
care about us they don't take care
that's a values issue
because because if you see those
comments once or twice about ramsey that
gets fixed
we take serious the way we care for
people
there's a values issue there and how you
and our leadership team have drilled
that into us
it's not acceptable and i think that it
there's another way to get away from the
disgruntled employees
if you make a mistake i want to caution
something don't go to glassdoor
and facebook to get a review on a
company well the problem is that's
usually disgruntled people well not and
it's not only that it's
um you don't even know if it's real
because it's anonymous
it's like a yelp review on a restaurant
you can't trust a yelp review that's
true
because uh what happened with yelp was
that competitors would jump on
and trash the restaurant as if they were
a customer and they weren't being
manipulated that's what's happening with
glassdoor glassdoor is losing its um
losing its credibility fast that's not
credible but i think if you look at
customer reviews
vendor reviews that's going to also give
you a sign as to
how does this how does this organization
treat people in general
yeah i think to me
if i'm her looking for a job with an mba
fresh out
and she couched it in the in the
not only finding her sweet spot which
you obviously described beautifully but
uh i think sometimes people look for
the uh
income the benefits the job description
and they leave out the character
yes and the culture the sense the
culture
the spirit of the place the values of
the place absolutely which those are the
things that could destroy you
you could be in your dream job dave in a
horrible culture and you won't last six
months yep
exactly exactly that is absolutely the
case you will not be living the dream no
yeah that's that's it that's what i was
talking about yeah very good